[Musique]
donc tu peux nous dire ce que tu es en
train de faire là tu serais pas en train
de draguer la belle demoiselle à côté de
toi
banier et la vanille et il a pas unis
donc tu veux manger des knacki chez cvs
j'étais censé en 2d censés aller dîner
ensemble
pourquoi tu changes ton aversion pour
quoi
[Musique]
je le redis du coup vous êtes chic même
beaucoup ces petites boucles d'oreilles
a qui vont avec la barre et hyper
tendance
non mais tu y arrives à manger du pain
perdu après avoir pris un an une entrée
un plat chez bénédicte ne t'a pas tout
manger aussi
[Musique]
deux femmes
oh
[Musique]
non
ok
[Musique]
mécontent
là
l'important est la phase on connais pas
toutes leurs baux est en fait pas du
tout sa famille fait il est tous les
traités et ce matin chantal mais une
nouvelle session d'écriture magic pour
un projet déjà bien entamée
[Musique]